today on the matt welsh show in one of
the most pathetic and cowardly displays
we've seen in a long time a comedian
issues a lengthy written apology for
taking a picture with dave chappelle
what can we learn from this sad
spectacle if anything and is it time to
stop our obsession with taking covet
tests the florida surgeon general thinks
so plus a school district in virginia
stops grading homework assignments in
the name of racial equity and an nfl
player storms off the field in the
middle of a game because but but what
we're told by the media is he's really a
victim in the middle of a mental health
crisis is anybody responsible for their
actions anymore or is every bad thing
just the result of poor mental health
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
well now introducing a new sponsor that
i'm very excited about these are uh it's
good ranchers and you know there's one
thing two things i love good stories and
great meat
and uh one such company that has has
both a great story and fantastic meat is
good ranchers we'll figure out how to
start this copy at some point but we're
just going to go with it right now they
are the exclusive meat company of the
daily wire for good reason they have 100
american meat steak house quality and
it's all for an affordable price over 85
percent of the grass-fed beef in stores
and online is imported from overseas
which undermines american farms and
ranches and often causes them to close
down if you shop good ranchers today to
support american made that means you're
helping to put the small farms back on
top and you're also just getting great
meat that's the most important thing
plus you can use my code which is walsh
for thirty dollars off that's the
biggest first purchase discount code
goodrancher says evan give ever given
out which means that there's never been
a better time to buy you can support
american farms and ranches and get
delicious t-bones gourmet burgers rib
eyes and more mouth-watering cuts in the
process visit goodranchers.com wall
street use code wall should check out to
get 30 off any one of their variety
boxes so visit goodranchers.com walter
use codewall should check out to get 30
off any of their variety boxes visit
again goodranchers.com walsh today to
save 30 off on your box delivered
straight to your door today
you know it's always good to have
positive role models in life but in a
country where those are often hard to
come by it seems like sometimes you have
to settle for negative role models and
the useful thing about a negative role
model is that he can show you exactly
how
not to respond in a given situation
which will also tell you exactly how you
should respond you know he's providing a
road map in his own way and that's the
great service that cowards provide for
all of us and that's why we should be
grateful in some ways to leftist
comedian patton oswalt today who over
the course of the past two days has
unwittingly offered himself as a prime
example of everything you shouldn't be
and shouldn't do as a man or simply as a
as a human being so it all began um well
really it began it began shortly after
oswald was born i guess it takes a
lifetime to make cowards of this quality
but we don't have time to go back that
far so we'll start this week
just a few days ago when oswalt was
performing at a comedy club apparently
in seattle and his uh his as he says
dear friend of 34 years dave chappelle
texted him and invited him to come next
door to the arena where chappelle was
performing um
doing his own performance and he said
that that oswald could do a guest set
there at his performance so chappelle
was at an arena because he was a big
popular comedian and patton oswalt was
at a small club because nobody cares
about him but chappelle said why don't
you come over and you can perform in
front of my bigger audience you know
it's a nice thing to offer
um i now why did chappelle offer that i
guess chappelle was angry with his
audience that night and wanted to punish
them by subjecting them to patent oswald
i don't know we can't be sure exactly
but oswalt took him up on on the
invitation
and later that night he took a picture
with dave chappelle and posted it to his
instagram but the rage mob didn't like
that
the trans bullies and their lackeys
decided that patent oswald shouldn't be
friends with dave chappelle
why well of course because dave
chappelle has opinions about gender that
are pretty well really pretty liberal
actually all things considered but still
slightly out of lockstep with the
orthodoxy of the day
so he's a heretic he's he's now we
should remember he's he's just barely a
heretic
his opinions about gender are still by
the standards of
uh like 10 years ago
are pretty radical far left but by the
standards of today they're you know
maybe moderate at best
and that means
that nobody can associate with them the
rage mob the trans mob the raging
transmop yelled at patton oswald for
daring to continue a friendship with a
man that he's known for three decades i
mean and how dare he really oswalt
didn't even ask the strangers on the
internet for permission
before choosing to continue his
association with this person
and they were stunned by the insult and
they let him know it
and so of course what does pat oswalt do
well he apologizes profusely and at
length complete with a photo of him
sitting ruffly at his desk like a child
in time out hoping that daddy isn't mad
at him anymore here was his uh follow-up
post on monday after desperately
explaining
how he ended up in the proximity of dave
chappelle and trying to justify his
decision to be photographed in the
heretics company
um rather than simply stoning him to
death on the spot and setting his corpse
on fire as a true ally would have done
oswalt says this
we oswald and chappelle 100 disagree
about transgender rights and
representation
i support trans people's rights anyone's
rights to live safely in the world as
their fullest selves
for all the things he's helped me evolve
on i'll always disagree with where he
stands now on transgender issues but i
also don't believe a seeker like him is
done evolving learning
you know someone that long see the
struggles and changes it's impossible to
cut them off impossible not to be
hopeful and open and cheer them on
also i've been carrying a lot of guilt
about friends i've cut off who had views
with which i couldn't agree or changed
in ways i couldn't live with sometimes i
wonder
did i and others cutting them off make
them dig their heels in deeper
fuel their ignorance with a nitro boost
of resentment in spite
i'm an lgbtq ally i'm a loyal friend
there's friction in those traits that i
need to reconcile myself and not let not
let cause feelings of betrayal in anyone
else and i'm sorry truly sorry that i
didn't consider the hurt this would
cause or the depth of that hurt
i've been messaging a lot on ig today
and the back and forth has really helped
guide me in the writing of this
i deleted a lot a lot of posts in the
comment thread critical ones from lgbtq
writers and posts by turf
anti-trans orcs looking for clicks and
giggles
i wanted a nice comment thread about the
pick with my friend ugg
so easy to think someone else needs
growth and miss the need in yourself
but i'm gonna keep trying
so there you go he's sorry truly sorry
but he wants you to know that he's only
remaining friends with the guy that he's
known for almost four decades in an
effort to cure him of his ignorance and
help him evolve so this is like this is
an evangelical mission you see
he's hoping to convert chappelle to to
induct him into the gender ideology cult
and that that's the only reason you're
staying friends with him
now naturally he never explains
what chappelle is wrong about when it
comes to gender
he also never explains how exactly
anyone could be hurt much less hurt with
such great depth
just because a comedian they like is
friends with a comedian they don't like
but those questions are irrelevant
he is just a mouse much like the one he
voices in the one single pixar movie
that my kids refuse to watch because
they say it's boring scurrying about
fearful and and confused
i just hope that in all his scurrying he
doesn't accidentally bump into this
other comedian who has said way more
problematic things about trans people so
patton oswalt uh watch out for this guy
his name is also patton oswalt watch you
said this is for like families and kids
because this sounds really grim and
creepy well you didn't let me finish
because we're also gonna have men in
bright clothing and makeup up time out
do you mean like
like transvestites right
well technically yes but they're gonna
keep going so that they're clowns
you realize a clown is just a
transvestite that doesn't stop
like if you like if you
if you saw a guy in lipstick and i
should be like timmy leave him alone
that's his own thing the guy's like oh
no hang on
like oh timmy he's a wonderful clown get
over there
i didn't know you'd use a whole tube of
lipstick on one cheek please
entertain my child
run at him out of the darkness he'll
love it
well i don't know how long ago that was
but it didn't look like it was all that
long ago
and there is of course a direct link
here
out of all the adults
bowing to cancel culture now and
especially to trans cancel culture to
lgbt cancer culture
precisely none of them
have obeyed these rules their whole
lives
because these rules as they stand right
now didn't exist their whole lives
most of them being empty gutless cowards
have lived their whole lives
trying to avoid the see the sin of of
wrong think
so they've been trying to engage in
group think and avoid wrong think their
whole lives but the problem is that the
thoughts which qualify as wrong and
right
tend to change
and what this means is that by obeying
the thought police of today
you will inevitably end up disobeying
the thought police of tomorrow
because the rules are arbitrary and they
change and it's designed that way
and because we live in in eternal now
where nothing is ever allowed to simply
stay in the past
and we're all called potentially to
answer for everything we've ever said or
done no matter when we said or did it
the people who've been trying to stay up
on the rules will always be in violation
of them
it's a losing game
but it's the only one they know how to
play
it it's too late now for a guy like
oswald to suddenly grow a spine a mind
of his own an intellectual identity of
his own
he's doomed to finish his life as he's
lived until now lying prostrate before
the mob
begging to be loved and accepted or at
least pitied if he can't have love and
acceptance
you know a few years ago when oswalt was
uh jumping on the dog dog pile to
slander the covington catholic kids as
racists
he tweeted this about them
he said that they are quote bland
frightened forgettable kids who will
grow up grow up to be bland frightened
forgotten adult wastes
that was a grown man talking about 15
year old kids at the time by the way
but he should have been talking to a
mirror
because he described himself and his ilk
perfectly
bland frightened forgettable
couldn't have said it better myself
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
uh you know i'm such a pushover i have
to tell you my um
my daughter has been begging me for
months now
uh she's eight years old she's been
begging me for months now to get her
ears pierced
and for some reason she really wants to
have needles stuck in her ears and then
hang ornaments from them
and um hang ornaments from the wound i
don't i don't really understand that
desire
but uh especially coming from someone
like my daughter is zero pain tolerance
like zero she stubbed her toe yesterday
and i ran into the room because it
honestly sounded like she was being
stabbed
um
and yet somehow she wants to have this
done to her i don't know why and she's
been begging me and and i keep saying no
because you know you're too young
and uh you don't need to do that and
just stop it we're not doing that and my
wife has been conspiring with her to
convince me because she thinks my
daughter's old enough but i've stood
firm you know i've said
you know
maybe when you're 16 or something you
get the airspace and then two nights ago
i noticed
um a crumpled up piece of loose-leaf
paper in the kitchen and uh and then i
opened up it was a note from my daughter
that she had written and it said please
daddy can i have my ears pierced i love
you
and i asked my wife when she wrote the
note and she told me that um
my daughter apparently had written it
you know this this very heartfelt
lengthy note she had written it a couple
of weeks ago but then didn't give it to
me i guess because because i've been so
gruff about the the ears pierce thing
that she figured i would say no so she
ended up not giving it to me and she
like threw it away
and that was all it took for some reason
it was uh it was that pathetic little
note scribbled on loose leaf left
pitifully in the kitchen
that broke my defenses and uh the guilt
trip landed successfully
and uh i told her that you know she can
have the ears pierced if she wants i'm
i've i'm
continually discovered that i'm very
easy to manipulate and i realized that
and i also realized that that my
daughter's smart enough that this might
have all been a plan on her part
because what my kids have started to
realize is that if you want to get what
you if you want to get something from me
uh whining is never the way to do it
but
to just sort of suffer in silence
in that kind of pathetic pitiful way
that kids do that's that's what will get
me
and then you end up getting everything
you want
um
all right we'll we'll start with this i
i think this is important florida
surgeon general joseph ladapo
is talking about moving away from
testing and this has we'll play another
clip in a minute here but this has the
media of course very upset
because everywhere else in the country
they're testing everybody every 30
minutes you know every time you go into
another building you got to take a test
um every time when you wake up in the
morning you got to take a test you go to
work you got to take a test
if you have a if you if you have a runny
nose take a test if you don't have a
ready nose take a test
and that's that's the general strategy
and that's why they're running out of
tests everywhere it's hard to find the
tests people are hoarding them and
everything
they're all these really pathetic people
in media that over christmas were
tweeting pictures of like boxes of tests
that they got as christmas presents and
they were so excited about it but in
florida um as they have been doing
from the beginning of of all of this
they're taking a different approach so
here's the surgeon general saying that
we need to get away from what he calls
this testing psychology
we're going to be working to unwind
the sort of testing psychology
that our federal leadership has managed
to
unfortunately get much most of the
country in over the last two years we
need to unwind this testing sort of uh
um
sort of uh planning and living one's
life around testing
without it we're gonna be sort of stuck
in the same cycle so you know it's
really time for people to be living to
you know to make the decisions they want
regarding vaccination um to enjoy the
fact that many people have natural
immunity
time for people to start living what
seems like reasonable advice now that
we're going into uh we're going into
year
three of this
and maybe three years later it might be
time
maybe now three years into this you can
finally start living your life that's
the way that i would look at it uh a few
thoughts on this but first
here is cnn's tv doctor this is um
i don't know this guy's name doesn't
matter uh their tv doctor explaining
why this is completely wrong and
horrible and lots of people are gonna
die if we get away from the testing
psychology listen does he have a point
and and if not why
no
and in fact it's hard to believe those
comments came from the surgeon general
of one of the largest states in in this
country and his words echo what the
former president
of the united states donald trump said
said in june of 2020 when he told a huge
crowd in uh
in tulsa oklahoma that the only that the
the downside to testing is that you find
so many cases and then he told his
his people to slow the testing down
please
the problem isn't that testing is
finding people who are fine
the problem is that we don't have enough
tests
and then if if we're looking to do what
and i completely agree with dr offit to
keep our schools open
one of the major things you would do is
test even more
to find people find kids find teachers
who are positive isolate isolate them
for a few days and keep the rest of the
school open the problem is that when you
have so much virus in the community and
you're trying to keep businesses open
without testing you're allowing the
virus to continue to spread unabated so
if anything we need to do much more
testing not bury our heads in in the
sands of florida
and hope for the best
oh less testing we need more testing
maybe if everyone's getting tested three
times a day make sure we test them five
times a day
here's here's my recommendation this is
my non-medical
recommendation
as a non-medical expert
um
if you have tests just just you know
throw them away
live your life
here's here's the here's the strategy
it's actually really simple
and this is basically how people
operated
um
for most of human history up until three
years ago
if you're sick
then stay home
and if you're not sick then go about
your business
it's really as simple as that
you know you don't you don't need a test
to confirm i i
over over the christmas break i'm
seeing some of these news reports about
people standing in line if they if they
can't get the rapid test they're
standing in line for hours in the cold
and you're standing in line in for hours
in the cold to find out if you're sick
you might not have been sick by the time
you get to the front of the line now you
are
the thing about being sick is that
usually it's pretty clear when you're
sick
you have you have symptoms you don't you
don't want to leave the house
you have a fever i mean these are the
things you're looking for
and let's say you have a cough and a
fever and you're feeling miserable and
all the rest of it
but you're but it could be covered it
could not be covered who cares if
whether it's coveted or not
just stay home
drink lots of fluids
try try to eat well
get a lot of rest
this is how people have been responding
to sicknesses of this type for thousands
of years
and if you're feeling okay then then go
about your business i mean this is
obviously not sustainable
we have been sustaining it for three
years and paid an enormous price for it
and this is not sustainable in the long
term it's already been a long time this
is not a sustainable on a permanent
basis
where uh you know
anytime someone has a case of the
sniffles we got to test them and if it
turns out that they have this virus
which is ex especially especially now
without with omnicorn is extremely mild
for almost everybody
now they got to stay home for you know
fi well now now the cdc says five days
before it was ten days
and over the last couple of weeks they
said you know we know we said ten days
but actually more it's five days
where did that change come from
was there some sort of scientific
breakthrough
did they make some kind of discovery in
a lab somewhere that let them know that
actually you only have to isolate for
five days
no this was a political decision it was
also it was also a practical decision
it's just not practical to tell people
to stay in their homes for 10 days
because they have the sniffles
especially if as it turns out people can
get this the virus more than once
and most of the time it's going to be
very mild but so what multiple times a
year potentially you got to stay home
for two weeks
when you're hardly sick at all
so they made that change just for
practical reasons
and that's why i you know i feel like
we're fully justified in for practical
reasons does this this is about it's
about it's about liv being able to live
a life for practical reasons just say
stop testing
if you're sick stay home it's not that
difficult
all right here's another thing that's
not difficult and it was obvious to most
of us we talked yesterday about how many
of these common sense observations
uh that that many of us have been making
for years
have very slowly now been um endorsed
by the media
people in the media who would have
shouted us down and did shut us down for
years for saying it now they're saying
the exact same thing so here's the
headline from cnn um and it's a question
not they're not quite ready to make a
statement yet but it's a question and
they're saying can weight loss help
protect against covet 19
can it hmm i don't know it says in the
holiday season when the average american
can easily pack on a few pounds experts
say there's another reason to pay
attention to your weight covet 19.
people who are overweight or obese are
at a much higher risk of much more
severe disease and even death from cover
19 and one new study suggests that
losing weight can reduce that risk one
study suggests that now let me uh
clarify for you it's not one study to
suggest that every single study that's
looked at this has found that
and that's also true by the way of like
almost every disease
you know if you're if you're obese
then you're going to be at a greater
risk when it comes to almost any illness
because you're you're unhealthy you're
starting from a baseline of being
unhealthy
you're gonna have a better shot against
literally any sickness if you're in good
physical shape
um
now that's that's the case generally
but there does appear to be something
unique about covid where you are
especially susceptible to for whatever
reason you're especially
susceptible to it if you're obese
especially severely obese
um
so it says the obesity epidemic has been
a threat to americans health health for
years it's the second leading cause of
preventable death after smoking
um one study found that 30 percent of
coven 19 hospitalizations we're in
people with obesity
and uh and then it goes off i mean but
but there's no reason to keep reading it
really because this is
this is something we've already known
but you're not allowed to talk about it
for a number of reasons
one of course we know it's the body
positivity movement
and you're not supposed to make anyone
feel bad about their body
and also there can't be any element of
personal accountability
now if we're talking about
you know the personal accountability in
in the sense that we're yelling at
people to go get vaccinated that's okay
we're allowed to do that
but what we're not allowed to do
is um
advocate for lifestyle changes
that's the big no-no
because
in our culture your lifestyle is sacred
however whatever style the style with
which you've chosen to live your life is
a sacred thing
and if your lifestyle involves putting
on 200 extra pounds of lard on on your
frame
and walking around with it till it kills
you well then that's
you are you are blessed for making that
choice
that's the the default reaction which is
why the left of the media has been so
slow to point out that um
if you really want to protect yourself
from covid
lose some weight
i mean if you're morbidly obese
and you've been triple vaccinated
you know that's you're not helping
yourself much you're not helping
yourself as much as you could be if you
would just
maybe hop on the treadmill lay off the
french fries something like that a
little bit more um on the covet end of
things
this is from
a tweet from carol markowitz is a
columnist for the new york post
she says new york state department of
health warns that they don't have enough
paxlovid or monoclonal antibody
treatment and therefore white people
need not apply
and then she links to the information
sheet from the new york
state department of health
talking about the antibody treatments
which which
have been therapeutics that have been
very successful in
treating people who are infected with a
covid
but they're running out of supplies
and so they got to start making
decisions about who gets them and now
they're deciding on racial grounds so
from the from the little fact sheet here
it gives you the eligibility
requirements and here's what it says
there's a little bit of euphemistic
language here a little bit but not much
it says eligibility
oral antiviral treatment is authorized
for patients who meet all of the
following criteria
age 12 years and older
weighing at least 88 pounds okay
um test test positive for cover 19.
that makes sense
have mild to moderate coveted symptoms
all of this makes sense so far
able to start treatment within five days
of symptom onset because if you start it
too late then it's not going to do you
much good
and then
have a medical condition or other
factors that increase their risk for
severe illness
what kind of medical conditions are we
talking about
non-white race or hispanic latino
ethnicity should be considered a risk
factor as long-standing systemic health
and social
inequities have contributed to an
increased risk of severe illness and
death from covet 19.
so i said that there's some euphemism
here but
but actually not really
this is from the new york state
department of health
explicitly saying
that if you want to get this treatment
you have to have a non-white race
singling out one race in a negative way
and saying everyone but them
and this is already absurdly grotesquely
illegal it's not even close to legal
and um
there's there's no justification for
this that can make it legal but what
they're what they're arguing is that
well if if you're if you're a non-white
race then you've been subject to
systemic inequalities you haven't had a
chance to have access to the same kinds
of uh
the same kinds of treatments and
therefore we got to balance things out
you know maybe kill off a few of the
whities
we could balance things out that way
if you were really worried about
giving out these treatments
and um
especially focusing on people who have
been the victims of systemic inequality
or whatever
then
it would be one thing if they said well
we're going to prioritize uh people of a
certain income level
you know we're going to prioritize the
poor
i still would not be in favor of that
when it comes to potentially life-saving
treatment
i mean you should be excluding anyone
based on race or or or income or
anything else
but if you're actually concerned about
inequalities and you know making sure
that people who haven't had the
opportunities get the opportunities
then that's what you would do
and notice again i think i think it's
worth uh worth reiterating how
they're they're not singling you know
they're they're they're signaling
white people out in a negative sense
you know and i think that's that's
really significant they're saying
members of the non-white race are the
ones that were that we're gonna that
we're gonna help completely illegal and
absurd all right let's move on to the to
this here
um as we lead into the holy anniversary
of the most sacred day of remembrance
which is january 6th the media wants to
make it clear that one person you may
not remember or mourn on that day
and hopefully by now you've thought
about what you're going to be doing on
january 6th
and uh you're going to have a moment of
silence and and hopefully you have i
know in my family we've got all kinds of
activities planned for that day
um because this is now our most our most
sacred day
but while you're doing that
uh the one person you're not allowed to
think about or mourn or remember is of
course ashley babbitt
even though ashley babbitt was the one
person killed directly by violence on
january 6th is just that it was violence
from the capitol police towards her
now you could mourn aoc instead
for example who wasn't killed
but almost died of fright when she found
out that some people were trespassing in
a building next door
but ashley babbitt doesn't deserve our
sympathy and the media makes that clear
and now they've begun publishing hit
pieces
about this woman who's been dead for a
year and there have been multiple
articles like this but here's one from
the the ap it says
if i pull this up um
it says ashley babbitt a martyr
her past tells a more complex story
and it goes on to it's a long story here
uh mostly dealing with kind of like a
love triangle that ashley babbitt was
involved in it says the first time
celeste norris laid eyes on ashley
babbitt the future insurrectionist had
just rammed her vehicle three times with
an suv and was pounding on the window
challenging her to a fight
norris says the bad blood between them
began in 2015 when babbitt engaged a
months-long extramarital affair with
norris's longtime live-in boyfriend
when she learned of the relationship
norris called babbitt's husband and told
him she was cheating
um and then she showed up and they got
into a fight and um
and that's basically it that's
that's the dirt they dug up on ashley
babbitt
after a year the dirt is that she uh had
an extra marital affair and then got
into a fight with the
with her
lover's girlfriend or whatever
now
think about the fact that the ap
thought it was worthwhile printing this
because ashley babbitt is supposedly
being presented as some sort of martyr
which which by the way she's not
i haven't heard anyone really do that
i haven't heard anyone say that ashley
babbitt is a martyr
i haven't seen anyone
there aren't any monuments or as far as
i know statues being built to her
i haven't heard anyone suggest that
there ought to
be um i haven't seen any any uh murals
anywhere or anyone argue that there
ought to be murals ever
okay we're not renaming streets ashley
babbitt lane
we're not talking about renaming
buildings and schools
um there aren't there's not even any
legislation the ashley babbitt act
that's what happens when you make a
martyr out of someone
and that's of course what they exactly
what they did with george floyd
and yet with ashley babbitt we get uh
as i said multiple articles
talking about i guess this one incident
from her life
um
while george floyd who who literally is
being presented as a martyr and a saint
basically a canonized saint
in the secular church of leftism
were the articles about him forcing his
way into a woman's home at gunpoint and
robbing her
the fact that he was a serial felon
a drug-addled violent man is that now
relevant are we allowed to talk about
that finally
or dante wright as you've heard many
times on this show
i mean really a violent psychopath
sociopath
i don't think you could think of or name
a single blm martyr
who um
was not guilty of far worse things than
ashley babbitt
and yet of course with every single one
of those people uh if you're to talk
about any of that you'll be told that
well what do you do that's had nothing
to do with anything that doesn't justify
right isn't it that the line you always
hear
i know i've heard it a million times
especially with dante wright
even though he did all of these terrible
things he shot a kid in the in the head
paralyzed him for life
robs a woman at gunpoint
carjacked somebody
what i am continually told is that none
of that is relevant because it doesn't
that does not justify him getting shot
in the moment during that traffic stop
you know kim potter didn't know about
most of that and and none of that is
relevant
so if ashley babbitt
rammed her car into someone and got into
a fight over a guy
even if she was kind of a nutcase
whatever but
how does that justify
her being shot by a capital police
officer when she was unarmed
and she was crawling into a window
and it seems to me that they that
this is a small woman and a large man
nobody else fired their gun
none of the other capital police
officers some of them now after the fact
have gone on cnn they talked about it
was a war zone and they've been
traumatized by it
but in the moment
none but that one
thought that the situation had gotten to
the point where it was justified to use
lethal force
how does any of this vindicate that is
the question of course it doesn't at all
all right this is from the daily wire it
says um
arlington county virginia recently
introduced a proposal for a new grading
system based on the idea of equity that
would allow an unlimited number of
retakes on assignments
ban extra credit and would block grading
on homework assignments according to fox
news
in response numerous teachers from
arlington slammed the proposal saying
that it would essentially give children
a free pass and dramatically reduce the
quality of education in the county
proponents of the new system claim that
having certain standards like having
late penalties in education often harms
poor children who may not have access to
resources necessary to complete
assignments on time
this is always tough for me especially
when it comes to
these changes to the way we approach
homework
because
i actually agree
that
forget about grading homework
assignments i don't think that there
should be homework assignments at all
and we're seeing more and more school
districts they're moving away from
homework or they're giving out homework
where they're not grading it and if
you're not grading it then effectively
you know you might as well not be giving
it out at all
and i agree with that i think that's the
right move it's just that they're doing
it for all the wrong reasons
and that's the problem
it's got nothing to do with racial
equity whatsoever
okay it's not like um non-white children
are more impacted or victimized by
homework
that that's that's something that
children of all races have been
suffering for for decades
but uh
i don't like it as a policy
because i happen to think you know i
think that you're the time that kids
spend at home with their families that
that time is important
and if they're going to public school
they already spend way too much time
there in that government building
doing what government employees tell
them to do
allegedly doing what they're told to do
anyway
uh and once you go home that's time with
your family
so i don't like the idea of the school
system intruding on that time at home
you've already got though it's the whole
most i could say from experience as most
of us can
95 of the homework assignments you're
given anyway are just busy work
they the teachers give it to you because
that's what you do you give homework
assignments
um
and they figure well you're you're
leaving you're going to have a few hours
at home we might as well give you more
stuff to do
but the kids are there for six to seven
eight hours a day if not longer
you need to be able to provide them a
complete education within that time if
they're there for seven hours a day five
days a week nine months a year for 12 or
13 years that that's a that should be
enough time
while they're in the building to provide
them with a quality education
and to get all of your lessons in
and if you can't then you got to start
looking at what you're how you're
spending that time
my favorite thing when i was a kid is
you'd have these classes where
you do almost nothing in the actual
class like you'd watch movies
i i still remember i took i took as i
mentioned before i took three years of
spanish
i still don't know
a word of spanish i know how to say
bench in spanish that's the only thing i
know how to say
or bank i still haven't figured out
which one it is banco
but
one of my spanish classes
we spent i think it was uh
maybe two weeks watching the movie
selena
with jennifer lopez
and that was that was our that was our
lesson plan was just to sit there and
watch the movie selena but then she
would still send us home with homework
to do once we got home
and i can remember even as a kid
thinking well we're in the class right
now why not turn the movie off and we'll
do this here and then i can go home and
just be home
so i'm in favor of that get rid of get
rid of
homework shouldn't be graded shouldn't
be giving it out at all but
even when they do the right thing
they do it for the wrong reasons
that's what we find so often
um
and uh finally before we get to the
comment section i wanted to mention this
headline as well deadline reports
spiderman no way home is now the 10th
highest grossing movie at the box office
with 610 million dollars probably more
than that this is a few days old
i just wanted to say i mean very rarely
do i actually see these big blockbuster
movies when they're in theaters and i
did see this one i took my kids to see
it over the over the christmas break
and a couple spoilers here
um
and i hate to be so predictable but i
have to tell you that i didn't like the
movie i know it seems like everyone
loves it it's got like 105 on rotten
tomatoes everyone loves the movie
um for me
the the spider-man movie exemplifies
everything that's wrong with superhero
movies
and first of all just to run through
some of the problems
there are no stakes
okay i don't mean s-t-e-a-k-s
um
there's nothing at stake okay there's no
there's no there's not a whiff of
suspense or narrative tension with these
movies because every problem
is solved with either miraculous
technology
or superpowers and okay that part i get
it's a superhero movie or or literal
magic now
it's been a while since i've seen one of
these and now apparently now in the in
the marvel superhero universe they have
actual wizards who can just who can just
fly in
and snap their fingers and make
everything okay
so there's no limits there's no rules
within the universe itself and then and
then so it's like watching someone play
a video game with all the cheat codes
there's no suspense to it there's
there's no point in watching it
i'm i'm fine obviously with uh
the idea of a superhero movie or a
science fiction movie
where things can happen in that world
that can't happen in reality that makes
sense it's fiction
but what you have to do and this is just
good writing
you set the rules for this universe in
the beginning
and the rules can be completely
different from the rules in our universe
that's fine but then you have to obey
those rules within the story
um
instead in this movie you know you could
have a super super villain from a
previous film
and uh you know he he took up multiple
films he was a big bad guy in previous
films and in this one
he was like turned good with a
contraption that a kid whips together in
a lab out of scrap metal in three
minutes
they never explained how he did it but
okay well you could do that now and if
that doesn't work a wizard can fly in
and brainwash the world
then there are multiverses and time
warps and you can go back in time and
forward a time
all of that can be utilized if the
narrative requires if the writers write
themselves into a you know write their
backs against the wall and they need to
get out of of a tough pinch well you
know just
go to a different universe bring a
wizard in whatever whatever you have to
do
and then you have like a superhero can
stop a train or something with one hand
in one scene
but then in the next he can be knocked
unconscious with a simple punch to the
head
doesn't make any sense
you see the rules are rewritten
depending on what the writers need for
each scene and it's lazy and boring it's
fun for the kids but it's bad filmmaking
that's my issue with spider-man
but the kids did enjoy it now let's get
to the comment section
this is from elizabeth says i've been
missing the show so much i've been going
back and re-watching old episodes well
it's a mistake elizabeth the old
episodes suck uh andrew says how come no
dw host is talking about joe biden's
repeating and agreeing with let's go
brandon yeah that's a shame that we
missed that but it feels like so long
ago now there's not much to say about it
that hasn't been said a million times
um that's one of the problems with
living in the internet age is that the
moment something happens
24 hours later everything that you could
possibly say about that event has
already been said
and in this case it's been um
it's been like a week and a half
but
it was funny there we go there's my
there's my analysis of that whole
situation
um
and and also it is very troubling once
again that we have a president who
clearly has dementia and has no idea
what's going on and uh
and uh and all of that
vin jk diesel says matt i would like to
call the new variant i would like you to
call the new variant the candy corn
variant
that would really make my day oh
omnicorn candy corn
i will take that joke suggestion under
advisement i'll think about it thank you
for that
um s di falco says matt you're
forgetting about willie nelson
as uh i guess one of the most beloved
americans or a universally beloved
american great show i missed i missed
you when you were away happy new year um
yeah there's a few people suggesting him
we're talking about who are the
universally beloved americans that are
left uh even if we're you know alex i'm
counting alastair back even though he
wasn't an american
now that we lost
uh now that we lost betty white we lost
john madden in the same week
um we lost norm mcdonald in the same
year
alex trebek
and
i think i
as far as i can tell yeah dolly parton
and denzel washington are the two we
have left
that everyone seems to like both of
those people
a couple other suggestions in the
comments willie nelson and then um
and also bill murray was probably bill
murray
willie nelson i don't know i think the
weed thing might preclude him from being
universally loved
he's probably too associated with that
and so i'm not sure that he that he
makes the cut i don't know
another comment says i think you're
missing the point of the marriage
requires amnesia article matt
the article was not about her hating her
husband but rather about how she loves
her husband in spite of his annoying
habits
the article ends with her saying that
she loves her husband and that she'll
stay with him forever in an age where
people get divorced the first time they
hit a bump in the road like honor jones
did the message that life with a spouse
and kids while aggravating on a daily
basis is worthwhile in the end is very
important
yeah if that was the message it would
have been a great article
but that wasn't the message she
literally said that she hates her
husband
you know and especially when you're a
writer and you're writing for a major
publication your the words you use
matter
and that word hate really matters
so i said that yesterday if if all we're
talking about is is anger and how
look sometimes there's anger in a
marriage and so it's an article about
how do you work through that anger and
love your your spouse in spite of that
that's fantastic many many articles many
books have been written on that subject
but there's obviously no place for
hatred in a marriage
which is what the article was about
and tercio says matt you probably used
too much butter for the cookies that's
why they melted when you bake them
cookies are like humans in that way if
you add too much fat they lose their
shape
you're supposed to use butter for
cookies
that was probably my problem
i i think i just took some
i just took some flour and water and i
and i threw it in the oven i think that
probably thinking back on it maybe that
was the issue
as you know the daily wire has led the
charge to sue the biden administration
for his vaccine mandates and now we're
taking it all the way to the supreme
court this friday the supreme court will
convene to hear arguments on the
legality and constitutionality of the
mandate which means this week is going
to be huge in our fight against medical
tyranny we have already over 1 million
signatures on our do not comply petition
but we want to get even more we're
greedy so you can help us send a message
loud and clear and head to dailywire.com
do not comply right now add your
signature to the petition if you haven't
already we're counting on you to help us
put a stop to this uh absolutely
disgusting and tyrannical federal
overreach go again to dailywire.com do
not comply now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
on sunday for the first time in well
over 30 years something interesting
happened during a jets game the
fascinating spectacle didn't take place
on the field of play but on the
sidelines where tampa bay buccaneers
wide receiver antonio brown decided to
quit in the middle of the third quarter
he took off his shoulder pads ripped off
his shirt pranced off the field while
his team was still playing and at that
point they actually were losing to the
jets and you could almost excuse this
behavior if the sheer
shame of losing to the jets is what
drove him off the field
it would at least be understandable but
that doesn't appear to be the motivating
factor now there are conflicting reports
about what led to his leaving uh the
field
brown's camp claims that the coach told
him to go into the game but brown
refused because he had an ankle injury
and couldn't play and then the coach cut
him on the spot that's what they're
saying the coach disputes that version
of events it's important to note here
that brown is a liar he's a horrible
teammate on literally every team he's
ever played on and he has a history of
quitting on his on his teams all of his
teams he's quit on all of them so
there's no reason to believe his version
also here's how it looked as he left the
field watch
very odd situation antonio brown boiled
over very upset on the sideline took off
his shoulder pads mike evans oj howard
trying to convince him to keep them on
obviously they were unable to do so he
tossed his shoulder pads stripped off
his shirt and glove threw those into the
crowd then ran across the field while
the teams were still on the field giving
the crowd a peace out sign i'll let you
know when we hear something official on
his status
you know you don't normally expect a guy
with a crippling leg injury to dance and
do jumping jacks as he's leaving the
field
so so i think he simply quit on his team
in the middle of the game that much is
obvious
the bucks did go on to win by four
points although morally speaking beating
the jets by four points is equivalent to
losing by 10 to a real nfl team but in
any case the head coach of the bucks
announced in the post-game press
conference that brown was no longer on
the team meanwhile brown took a private
jet back to his house in the middle of
the game
and when he got back to his house he
released a rap song
now i know you may be worried that i'll
play the song for you but you should
know that i would never waste your time
like that just kidding of course i will
here it is
[Music]
hit on
well there's no question that um the man
is a poet
maybe there's a little question mostly
because nobody knows what he was saying
there it sounds like he was rapping with
ten jolly ranchers in his mouth but
artistry aside as an athlete brown's
career is finished as it should be he's
an egomaniac he's a crybaby he's a
quitter
he abandoned his team in the middle of a
game and that's the cardinal sin in
sports to quit
or it used to be
but that was before the era of simone
biles when quitting athletes are now
viewed as heroes or at least as victims
who deserve our unending sympathy
and so that quickly became the narrative
in this case also
the ap published a piece uh with this
headline about antonio brown says
antonio brown's mental health is no joke
internet commenters were chastised for
daring to make jokes about the whole
situation quote uh from the writer rob
maddie he scolds us quote brown's mental
health is no joke to be trivialized by a
meme
yeah i mean you heard his rap song this
is a tortured artist we're dealing with
let us not trivialize him
it's not as though he's trivialized
himself right
maddie argued that even if brown is out
of the league forever now he should
still quote get the benefit of various
mental health services the nfl offers
players and team personnel
the other sports other sports writers
chimed in ross tucker said on twitter
i expressed significant concern about
antonio brown's mental health over two
years ago
the man needs help
and then writer bakari sellers tweeted
antonio brown is unstable and needs
mental health treatment the league
doesn't care as long as he runs routes
and catches passes without immediate
help and no football bad things could
happen
someone needs to wrap their arms around
him
now
this again is a grown man we're talking
about
someone needs to wrap their arms around
him
the author malcolm gladwell echoed these
concerns he says i'm stunned by the lack
of sympathy for antonio brown he's
clearly struggling
is this how we treat people who are
going through difficult times
struggling
the poor deer
the poor multi-millionaire athlete
how dare we be so callous to a person
suffering through such a difficult time
you know i just finished reading a book
about the donner party
which of course is the group of 19th
century pioneers who got stuck in the
mountains on the way to california and
half of them starved or froze to death
and then their corpses were eaten by the
other half
and needless to say
their whole experience was kind of a
bummer but it pales in comparison to the
plight of a tampa bay buccaneers wide
receiver
i mean no soul has ever suffered so much
as him
on monday afternoon the media asked
brown's former head coach about the
incident
and the questioning mostly revolved
around this this issue of poor antonio's
mental health
listen you've been someone that's
expressed genuine care and concern for
antonio how tough was it for you to see
what happened yesterday and to make that
call
yeah very hard and i i i wish him well i
hope
um if he needs help get some and uh
but um yeah i
it's very hard because i do care about
him
and um was there any type of
conversation with him before you made
that decision post game and was there
any sort of mental health evaluation
performed on him before he left the
stadium
no i have no idea
mental health evaluation performed on
him before he left the stadium
it's an nfl team it's not arkham asylum
how would that work exactly
meanwhile back on social media thousands
of random people who also apparently
happen to be expert neurologists all
decided that antonio brown must have cte
which is the brain condition
brought on by repeated blows to the head
it's been declared over and over again
that brown
isn't at fault for any of his actions he
got hit in the head one too many times
and somehow although nobody can really
explain how that caused him to act like
an enormous jerk
now the problem with this diagnosis of
course is that the people making it are
utterly and completely full of crap
cte is still quite mysterious we don't
know for sure how it relates to football
injuries or if it does
and even if it does we don't know how it
would cause people to act in certain
ways or if it does
in other words cte is an excuse for
antonio brown a rationalization
with no evidentiary basis
and which ignores the fact that brown
has been a selfish jerk for his entire
career it's not the it's not the
compounded result of 10 years worth of
concussive episodes he's always been
like this
so that is again an excuse
and the same can be said about the whole
mental health angle in general
you see all of this is part of the
general effort by so many in our culture
to remove agency from the individual
to turn everybody into victims into
patients into sufferers
none of us choose to act in in one way
or another way
rather the actions occur
the choices are made
and we are the victims of the results if
they don't go our way
it's like we're all constantly pleading
insanity for ourselves and one another
in the court of public opinion don't
blame anybody for anything
all bad choices are the fruits of mental
health problems
and blaming someone for a mental health
problem is like blaming them for
arthritis
that's the attitude anyway and it's
totally ridiculous
there are crazy people in this world who
cannot control themselves
who shouldn't be held morally
responsible for their actions
but those people aren't playing in the
nfl
they're sitting on park benches arguing
with squirrels
you know those kinds of people when you
meet them they aren't they aren't
mentally with it they aren't competent
they can't care at all for themselves
that's not the case for antonio brown
it's not the case for most of the garden
variety jerks and a-holes who get by on
the mental health excuse these days
for them the problem is not mental
deficiencies but deficiencies of
character
see we used to talk about and
acknowledge things like character and
virtue
before we decided that all of the
jackasses and schmucks in the world are
actually mental patients
and in antonio brown's case it's not
difficult to pinpoint where his trouble
really began
it begins with this he's a pampered
coddled superstar athlete
and so at the age of 33 he's been a
pampered coddled superstar athlete for
most of his life going back to high
school
and that means that he almost always
gets his way
it means people bend over backwards to
accommodate him and satiate him
it means they make excuses for him just
like they're doing right now they give
him more chances than he deserves just
like they're doing right now uh you know
my dad used to tell me that it's good to
get rejected sometimes it's good to fail
because it builds character and you have
to learn how to deal with not getting
what you want
but there are some people who have never
had to learn that lesson
and they end up morally stunted as a
result it's called being entitled it's
not that complicated most people in our
culture today suffer from
this entitlement disease to one degree
or another a guy like antonio brown has
it terminally
except it's not really a disease because
it's developed as a result of his own
choices his own moral habits
again it's not complicated he's not a
victim
and the more he's treated like one
the worse the problem gets
and that's why antonio brown and also of
course his army of enablers are all
today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
valdoski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
dr fauci accidentally admits that he
collaborated with the chinese communists
big tax suspends a sitting u.s
congressman for wrong think and the libs
and their collaborators gear up for the
sacred feast of january 6th check it out
on the michael knowles show